Or a helmet.
Oh my God.
Eddie Bravo's here.
Jesus Christ.
You guys haven't showed
earlier.
We're having a great time talking about a two dimensional beings.
What's up,
bro?
I'll choke you out with this shirt.
Nassa any,
you know,
I'm gonna make you regret wearing this fucking shirt.
Hey,
listen to high school.
We used to choke each other out.
That's like a DMP.
Could go ahead and check me out on it.
No,
no,
no.
Please don't.
I'm scared.
Let's do it.
No,
no,
no.
Eddie don't.
Please don't choke them unconscious.
No,
no,
please,
let's go.
He can't do it.
You know,
you think I'm afraid of this.
Let's,
no,
I,
I definitely don't think you're afraid of this,
which is why I don't want them to do it.
Touched,
not be pussies.
Choke me up.
Let me tell you a story first.
Let me tell you a story.
First.
Back when I used to work at the Strip club,
you're the one,
hold on Alex.
Sit down please.
Come on please.
We have to work together here.
Let's work together.
Come sit down.
Good luck and yeah,
have a seat.
Have a center.
Choke me out.
Alex please.
High School.
I know you did.
You told me he grabbed each other and you fall down and hit your heads.
It only takes like 20 seconds.
What were you gonna say about Strip club?
Back when I was a blue belt,
1995,
I worked in Strip club and,
and um,
there was this girl I was dating,
she never had any others.
She was a bartender.
She was seriously four foot 10 and bartenders and waitresses.
Always the best way to go to strip clubs.
I don't know.
You got to let him.
I will.
She was,
she was 92 pounds bartender,
the smallest girl and I showed her how to do a rear naked choke.
She was tiny.
Her name is Kimmy and the Strip club manager.
What's your size?
Big used to be buff but Fidesz.
Yeah,
but used to be pumping football player type manager.
You know,
you want those guys that manage strip clubs,
you know the intimidating looking big dudes.
And he had a corvette and he didn't believe in Jujitsu at all and she said,
he said she could choke me out with one of them Jujitsu moves,
I'll give her the keys to my corvette.
So she had to literally get on a bar stool and she was standing on a bar stool
and had to go around him and she went like this and he was just like this.
And then he went out,
lights out,
he dropped like a sack of potatoes.
He hit his head on the fucking floor and the impact of his head hitting the
floor woke his ass up and say,
so we hit the ground and then he pops back up and then he didn't know what the
fuck happened.
I was just sitting there going,
no you wouldn't.
I thought he faked it,
but that's what I'm getting.
People usually don't kick the ground pop back up.
Usually they hit the ground,
they're done and they need an ambulance,
but he popped right back up and he's like,
what happened?
Like bitch,
you need to give her your quarterback.
I'll pop right back up.
It was a,
it was a corvette.
Oh,
this was a thing I didn't about this about in the seventh grade.
During lunch,
some of the kids would choke each other out.
You put your hands up on their neck.
Kids don't do this.
I'm not teaching like Tom died box.
You can die doing this.
But then he'd be like,
the cheerleaders wanted to be shocked up and then they would show us out.
I probably did it about 300 times.
You go to school,
go to school where the bill hooks looks good.
He's not bill Hicks,
but we already went over.
This guy's talking about this
is you can put together a case where you fucking,
you know,
leave.
Can
you have just saw bill Hicks live?
I've known Alex since just a few years after all these guys.
Oh,
you got to see his old way.
Differs a bunch of holes for separation because you and I worked with somebody
that worked with him.
When you worked with thousands of people,
suddenly it's like,
oh,
we do the same person.
It's such overruled.
All you gotta do is just show those pictures of you like at 200 block this off.
I'm like,
Bill Hicks is never 20 and yoke you are you still jacked.
You were like a bodybuilder and I used to run like,
I think it's,
I wish I get in that zone again.
You can.
I had gotten this young where I ran six miles every other day and I lifted
weights for people.
Go,
dude,
you'd be bigger if you can work out three hours.
I was addicted and then I got on radio and TV and like try to drinking and just
stopped and it didn't work out for like 10 years,
getting like a hundred pounds.